-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well, and
now we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden held a virtual
meeting today with
Russian president
Vladimir Putin,
though it was weird
that they decided to do it
in the metaverse.
According to a new book,
hours after former president
Trump announced, in 2020,
that he had tested positive
for the coronavirus,
his health deteriorated
very quickly.
They kept him alive by
immediately hooking him up
to a camera and a microphone.
Senate Majority Leader --
[ As Trump ] That's my oxygen.
Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer
yesterday reiterated
his goal for Democrats
to pass the Build Back Better
spending Bill by Christmas,
the same night Joe Manchin will
be visited by three spirits.
New York governor Kathy Hochul
announced yesterday
that there are a total of
12 confirmed cases
of the Omicron variant of the
coronavirus across the state.
That story again --
There are 12,000 cases
of the Omicron variant in
New York state.
"We got 12.
We're sure that's it."
The fifth annual gingerbread
replica of The Capitol
made its debut yesterday,
but, sadly,
it's just been breached.
You know what?
He's so lovable,
you're still rooting for him.
During a new interview,
billionaire Elon Musk
said that his Neuralink company
hopes to start
implanting brain chips in humans
sometime next year.
Kind of intriguing, but I don't
think I'd get the first one.
I mean, you remember
the iPhone 1?
Exactly, you know?
You get the first chip,
and in three years,
everybody will be,
like, making fun of you.
"You got the 1?
Can you even watch
TikToks with that?"
Today was Maine Senator
Susan Collins' 69th birthday,
though she's confident
that she will remain 68.
[ Light laughter ]
They all left?
[ Laughter ]
Trump Tower recently
began selling a cocktail
inspired by former president
Trump called 45,
and it secretly reports to
a white Russian.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That really hammers home
how the last joke did.
[ Laughter ]
"Maybe it's them. Oh, it's not."
More than 30 people
recently spent the night
at an IKEA in Denmark
after a snowstorm
stranded them at the store.
And then they were
stranded another night
because they couldn't
find the exit.
And I didn't know this,
but in Denmark,
all their furniture
has normal names.
[ Laughter ]
It was announced today that
investment manager Peter Lynch
will donate more than
$20 million worth of art
to his alma mater,
Boston College's, art museum.
Lynch hopes the donation
will help Bostonians
learn to correctly pronounce
the word "art."
"No, that's aht.
That's aht, bro."
And, finally,
Instagram today launched
a so-called "Take a Break" tool.
A break from Instagram,
or as its otherwise called,
Twitter.
And that was the monologue,
everybody!